[Music]
hey everybody today we're gonna take a
look at my tips for working with design
systems in InDesign now we all work
differently and some of us kind of hack
things together instead of reading the
software manuals that's okay but too
often we hackers miss out on a whole
host of features that make our lives so
much easier now these are just a few
not-so-secret tricks I've picked up
working with InDesign for the past 10
years and hopefully you'll be able to
use these to save time the next time
you're working on a multi-page document
here's what we're going to cover in a
nutshell grids and master pages
setting up reusable typography styles
and using color swatches now here's a
side note if you're one of those people
who love using illustrator but haven't
broken into InDesign yet or or don't see
the point of it or you know are confused
this video is perfect for you but first
design systems what are they we're not
going to go too deep here but a design
system outlines the rules patterns and
elements that are used to make something
look like it should at its most simple
basic level a design system outlines
basic patterns like colored use and
typography and then the way that you use
the space available now when these
patterns are established it's really
tedious to keep entering in the right
settings in our design software and when
I was using illustrator for all of my
layouts
I would always copy and paste blocks of
type just to keep the formatting in
place but lucky for us InDesign has
fantastic features that that help us
automate the process of creating and
using and updating design systems so
today we're gonna be working on the
pebble coffee style guide pebble is a
fictional brand that I created I love
coffee and I've already established the
bones of a design system here in this
document that we're gonna edit today so
I'm gonna walk you through the process
of adapting this style guide to a new
brand or just reformatting it to fit
like a pretty significant brand
this template file is over a hundred
pages long and every single page has
actual copy on it not filler text so if
we were gonna update the design without
using these automated design system
features and reusable elements it would
take forever it would be like creating a
new document by the way the template
file we're working on is available for
sale in our shop at the futurecom so if
you want to follow along you can hit
pause go download that and then come
right back alright let's get started
okay so first we're gonna open up our
document and kind of give it a scroll
through you can see in the pages pane
we've got about a hundred pages of
content here that we need to update and
right above pages we've got our masters
pane we have a few masters in there that
we need to be aware of now whenever I
start something new I always begin with
the bones the grid so let's go ahead and
make the grids and guides visible in our
template now I have I have this feature
set to one of the buttons on on my mouse
this middle button here but you can
always use like a keyboard shortcut so
you notice how our entire design area is
nicely off-center to accommodate that
page number on the left well let's say
we want to get rid of that page number
and have equal margins all the way
around now individual pages can have
their own grid systems in InDesign but I
prefer to work with masters for grids
because you can apply masters to any
page and make big changes to multiple
pages at once so once you drag a master
on to the page all of the elements are
applied on page and it overrides the
page content we'll do that here
now you can tell if a page has a master
assigned to it because it'll have a
little letter flag on its thumbnail that
letter corresponds with the right master
above all right so if I go up to our
masters pane you can see I have a few
dedicated grids now I like nesting my
masters as well so you can see I've
applied the a grids master to the ones
with Mouse type headers it's it's a
master apply to the master that gets
applied to the pages welcome to the
matrix now obviously we want to edit our
grid so let's double click into this
master now you can see it's a blank page
with a solid color background and it has
our embedded grid to edit the grid
you're going to click layout and then
margins and columns and from here we can
reset our margins which is the clear
space around the border of the page our
columns which are used to divide up the
design area and the gutters which are
the spaces between the columns so let's
just reset these to be even on all sides
with pretty generous gutters in between
nice now you can see the guides have
changed everything is also symmetrical
now but it's not just changed here and
also change the guides on every single
page that has this master applied let's
open up our mouse type master now since
we don't have that nice wide margin on
the left anymore
I need to find a new place for the page
number so let's just move a few pieces
of the mouse type around and master
and voila now because all 100-plus pages
have one of these masters applied to
them
these changes are carried through the
entire template alright I'm gonna go
through the rest of the document and fix
up all the rest of the page layouts the
guides make it really easy everything
just kind of snaps right to pull it into
place as you as you drag them towards a
guide
[Music]
[Music]
all right looking good all of the pages
have been adjusted and we have new
layout now let's say this this company
decided to go with a more classic
typeface going through the document and
editing the formatting for every single
block of type would be crazy tedious
luckily the guy who made this template
is awesome and saved all of the
formatting types as paragraph style man
what a nice guy
so paragraph Styles paragraph styles are
saved
typography formatting to get to this
pane just go to window and then show
paragraph Styles now character Styles is
good too but the main reason that I
stick to mostly paragraph Styles is that
you can save things like line height and
paragraph spacing or margins into the
style and you can't do that with
character Styles character styles only
apply to the individual letters now I
use character styles as add-ons because
they can stack on top of paragraph
styles so I'll add character Styles like
light text and dark text once you have
this pane open you can see the entire
list of styles that I've saved the
document and each one of these is
represented within a master page called
typography and that's just because I'd
like to see all of my Styles on one page
this looks terrible but it's it's nice
because I like to see what I'm working
with you don't have to create this
master but it helps me one thing to
remember is that all of these Styles all
of these name styles aren't in InDesign
by default I save them by just clicking
the little Add button at the bottom of
the pane and naming them appropriately
if I can create styles you can too I
mean it's it's super easy so whenever
you have a new text block that needs to
be fixed up all you need to do is click
the text box on the page and then click
the style name and bam reformat it
super easy right so just like you can
nest masters you can also nest
typography styles within InDesign and
what I've done is I've based most of
these paragraph styles on the body text
style so I'm going to start there so
let's say this this company wants a more
classic typeface so I'm going to use one
of my favorites which is a scotch Roman
serif called Hercules we're gonna change
this paragraph which is assigned the
body text style we're gonna change it to
Hercules and then make some make some
adjustments so that it looks good
there we go okay so you can see that I
just edited one block of text and the
rest of the document hasn't been
disrupted or changed that's because you
can change a single block of text and
and what that does is it adds overrides
on to that block so what you see here is
they're the overrides are stacked on top
of the style just on this one paragraph
and you can tell because when you click
on this text box there's a little
diamond next to the name in the style
list and when you see that you know
there are overrides on that block but
since we want to apply these changes to
the rest of the document all we need to
do is is click on the reformatted text
box and then right-click the the
paragraph style and then click re-define
style and what that does is it saves
your overrides as the paragraph style it
overrides the existing settings and the
paragraph style and now the entire
document has been edited and you can see
that even our heading styles have
changed to the new font because they
were based on this style remember now if
you want to you can edit the style
directly by right-clicking and and
clicking edit style but I like to play
with things on page and then redefine
styles because then I know exactly what
it's gonna look like alright so what I'm
gonna do now is I'm going to go through
the rest of the styles and update them
to match the new look and feel
[Music]
all right so far we have a night and day
difference here from from when we
started but we're not done yet let's
take this one step further let's recolor
the whole document now whenever you're
working with InDesign you're gonna find
yourself in the swatch panel so to get
two swatches you just go to window and
then color swatches and you can see as I
scroll through that all of the colors
used in this document are saved here as
local swatches everything I mean even
down to the color of the body text is
colored using one of these swatches now
I am no color master in fact if you want
to learn color check out Gregg's class
on color it's color for creatives it's
awesome but what I want to do is just
kind of give this document a totally
different field by simply just changing
the black and white values and then
adding in maybe a few spicy accent
colors alright so I've got my new
palette here and I'm gonna pull from
this to edit the rest of the document
and and we're just gonna use this to
pull from to set all of our new hues and
save them as swatches now since
everything on page uses the current
swatches anyway what I'm gonna do is I'm
actually gonna edit the swatches
directly so to edit these swatch all you
need to do is right click on the swatch
and click swatch options now from there
you're gonna be able to copy and paste
the hex code right into the box and
that's it you can use the other settings
- I just find hex codes really really
easy so what I'm gonna do now I'm gonna
go ahead and get the rest of these
swatches squared away
[Music]
it's actually really cool about this is
as I'm going through changing the color
swatches everything that's assigned that
color that's associated with the swatch
gets changed in the actual document so
for example the pebble logo and the gray
color assigned to it and when I change
the swatch color it changed on the pink
so using color swatches is a great way
to make document wide changes color
without having to edit every single
thing and then you just have to go
through the document and look for
inconsistencies or errors where certain
colors clash as you can see we have
completely transformed the overall look
and feel of this document by using the
design system features built right into
InDesign this is a hundred and three
pages completely done in just a few
hours now if you didn't love InDesign
before you would love it after you
finish this project I hope this has been
helpful for all of you people who are
staring down the barrel of a long
document project and if you have any
other tips about working with design
systems in InDesign I would love to hear
them put them in the comment section
below or just say hi I'm gonna be stuck
in the comments as always and again if
you want a copy of this template you can
pick this up at the futurecom forward
slash shop it's a part of a product that
I've just released with a style guide
kit this kit comes with everything that
you've seen in the video a keynote
version of the template an Adobe XD
version of the template a 70 page guide
book that covers everything about style
guides a copy arsenal full of text that
you can copy and paste and use for your
next style guides directly with your
clients an example style guide from one
of our real live blind clients and then
there's tons of webinars and video
tutorials right there in the class and
honestly guys I am incredibly proud of
this product and I would love to see
each and every single one of you in the
next webinar for style guide customer
and for the 2,000 of you who supported
this product already thank you I've got
some surprises in store for you in the
next few weeks it's gonna be great
and listen you know if money is tight
especially right now use these tips that
we covered in this video to create your
own style guide template you know
tapping into the design system features
in InDesign makes things so much easier
I promise
as always guys thank you for watching I
want you to go out there and crush it
you got this don't forget to Like
subscribe we love you and we'll see you
next time